do you know what I watched I watched the
Kevin Hart documentary oh really
have you seen it no it's good I like his
fan [ __ ]
cuz I from a few people some comics I
got don't watch I think it's him like
boasting about himself all this I'm like
really and then J texting us have you
watched Kevin Hart documentary on
Netflix oh you'll know he goes I work on
computers and I'm inspired watch it he
was one the best doctors ever seen it's
a five part series do so obviously it's
it's his thing you know it's called
don't [ __ ] this up the stuff that he
left in that makes him look bad you just
can't help but love the guy I love him I
told you that yeah I know III he's one
of my so they leave in you know the
Himba cheated on his wife yeah they show
his like when he finds out you know I
was one of his best friends who did it
he talks about that they have a scene on
there cuz he has his like red paper cut
boys where the [ __ ] they calm his crew
they came up with all great and they're
all great his crews great yeah and
they're all doing their own thing right
but he has his trainer who's with him
all the time was his boy and they're
super close he's part of the red cup
boys or whatever it is and he you know
once he finds out one of his friends is
the one who tried to extort money from
the film the sex tape and bleak tit to
his wife once he found that out he had
this like horrible resentment in him and
he's like it's gonna come out one way or
the other and just came out and I was
gonna add it but I said not to let you
guys see it so him and his boys are
doing a show and Philadelphia some giant
arena and then flying back on his
private jet and they're drinking and
they're gambling and Kevin goes so I
decided to leave it in so you guys can
see how it is dude I was like I can't
believe he left this in because he was
drinking and something you know he has
this inside him it's gonna get out and
his his buddy who's his trainer his
friend he starts arguing so you tell me
you woulda made money from work for me
and a strain of successful Kevin he's
like are you [ __ ] me
yeah he goes you own a home [ __ ]
and he's belittling he's like you don't
make money you won't be [ __ ] without me
this trainer is huge
they are literally about to fight
they've got these boys get between them
the stewardess on plane called the cops
so they land the cops are there so Kevin
the next days I K you know I had this
horrible issue
come one well you know nothing but love
and so the next day they're all good but
the stuff he left in his house but his
dad is his dad in there they have to ask
that went you were supposed to host the
Oscars I got choked there's a strain of
shout to his trainer I got choked up cuz
they in doing shows in Australia and
they show him when he gets the call to
host the Oscars and he doesn't get that
one motion on the show eats emotionally
like his his buddy gets married but when
he gets a call from the Oscars I got
choked then gotta get him on the podcast
Oh cuz cuz cuz he called because he goes
okay it sounds you know I really
appreciate the opportunity hangs up in
the chemical areas and name he goes
would he say goes Chris Rock Bill Cosby
just threw their names I host the Oscars
and Kevin Hart and he starts talking his
mom and passed away he's like this is
for you I know you're watching I was
getting emotional he's like this the
biggest step in my career
and he's like emotional he's like I
can't wait and then it shows these
[ __ ] bloggers bringing up his old
tweets [ __ ] and they and they film and
they cover everything where he's a part
like his he said sorry fifty thousand
times but he even he admits he made a
mistake because his publicist goes Kevin
you're not dealing with this right you
have to acknowledge because he said his
this thing is if my son was gay I'd
whoop his ass I'd do this he didn't
acknowledge the violence part you said
oh I apologize That's not me but he
didn't actually own it and come out with
it yeah but it shows before he did the
video or anything his publicist and
steams like Kevin this is the this what
we're gonna have to do to make sure you
all get with all shoes and all that and
he's not listening to him and posts a
video from his bed and his boys who are
comments are clown like this my [ __ ]
Dini out of bed he goes he has three
chains on like he's [ __ ] easy
his eyes are barely open he's just like
hey listen he's he's just firing off
what he wants to do remember his
publicist like I'm telling you man
you're [ __ ] up your [ __ ] so you
can see all these companies stop [ __ ]
with them oh and his friends like he was
doing that movie with those same uh the
guy from Breaking Bad that movie
he's like Bryan Cranston's out as far as
doing PR with you because he's on
Broadway as a big lbgtq community up
there and Kevin goes oh no I get it
and she goes we do we need to issue an
apology goes time to watch Ellen I've
already done on there
Kevin that's like in a work man if
you're gonna do this you have to
acknowledge it he's like nah [ __ ] that
I'm not doing this and then it shows now
right that was like a year ago
it shows him now he's a guy [ __ ] up
he's a guy he's like there's a lot of
times I'm right because I was so wrong
on that here's I got in my head and I
I'm with you remember I came out with
like [ __ ] these people I'm with Kevin
he's right he's apologize but you watch
it Kevin even like yeah I didn't own it
I was just like no that's old [ __ ]
that's the way I thought I thought I was
doing the right thing about it on it
yeah he's he's I'm tired of
documentaries so by the way um just
really quick the men when I said that
Bill Cosby had about 20 specials he does
remember how he looked it up and it was
only one Bill Cosby yeah you're right
well I thought we looked it up no and
now boy I could find one album no we
found like he's done over 23 oh there's
like one hour Nara but we were looking
good how many spent yes how many one
hours he had years ago no this is about
a couple months ago and I was like oh
he's done 25 or something and we can
only find one for whatever reason I
looked it up on Rogan robo's like Jamie
was like there 23 is some crazy number
of hours like crazy like I'm saying like
Bill Cosby as [ __ ] up as he is we were
talking about what what he was as a
comic who will meet you and I were we
were all talking I don't know where you
go just cuz you mentioned Bill Cosby
with the Oscars oh yeah I'd comics but
he was so it's so tragic doing that
would see Kevin was such a big deal for
me like oh I want to see this
documentary man but you you so you can't
help but love [ __ ] for that to rise
getting [ __ ] for the think so it just
dumbasses online and I kill this dogs
[ __ ] or Gator comics but where he
wins he's ecology he wins every time but
he did what's funny is like you see how
good he takes care of the people around
him how grateful he is and how telling
you and how he gives tell all with my
own eyes and no one else did this he did
this on the DL this girl wasn't even as
they she was this this little gal who
was running back and forth and she was
probably like 40 and she was it was so
hard for her she was trying to all his
stuff and she some guy was like spilled
something and he just I could I watched
some clock ADIZ just watched clock
reached him pulls out like three four
hundred dollars and he just goes like he
goes you're doing a great job tonight
thank you and he did it really quietly
just
just to help that personality it's funny
since his dad died kidding right his dad
was the absent father absentee father
he just wasn't around could cocaine name
it he's he wasn't around
his dad's around now right and he has
some condition where he needs like all
this medical device and Kevin's bring
around the family in the and you know
the dad's not doing well he's like hey
Kevin so he takes him aside and again I
can't weekend lots of stuff in he's in
and they're like in this like sweet nor
in New York something he's like hey keV
you know I need disease and he goes dad
stop I don't need to run around I don't
need the whole sad story what do you
need he's out but brother I need I need
about seven granules I was gonna give
you twenty so just just come to me and
tell me how much you don't give me the
runaround yeah I'm gonna give you twenty
days or so that's more than enough
because alright go on
I love it be like [ __ ] I love it that
kind of money just to hear you give me
money man I gotta come to you and ask
you with my top [ __ ] is gonna [ __ ] dude
how much you gotta watch it man listen I
mean I got some stuff going yeah what do
you got going on doing this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]